on va en parler tout de suite avec
guylaine leclerc qui est la
vérificatrice générale du québec bonsoir
madame leclerc donc plus de 3 milliards
qui ont été prévues pour les deux grands
programmes d' aides aux entreprises
durant la pandémie des prêts des
garanties très bon et là vous parlez
dans votre rapport aujourd'hui d'un
manque de transparence dans les critères
d'octroi des soutiens jusqu'à quel point
il ya eu un manque de transparence
comprend 3 milliards dinars pour
l'emploi ce qu'on a constaté c'est que
on examine et 22 donc si acquis
représentent à eux deux cent cinquante
plus de 250 millions et sur ses 22 dos
et l'orne et d'anti fille 10,2 aussi qui
représente 68 millions pour lesquels les
critères on a utilisé le critère ses
modalités peuvent être ajustés par le
men et selon les besoins du dossier
alors faut savoir que dans le cadre du
pacte c'est le bureau régional
d'investissement québec qui rencontrait
les entreprises pour eux
et le bureau régional lui il y allait
selon les critères donc fallait ne pas
avoir à avoir été rentable auparavant
avoir des expectatives de profits que ce
soit dû à la ville mais lorsqu'on allait
vers le financement un majeur
investissement québec où le financement
spécialisées et bien là il y avait un
gay dans l'intervalle interne qui
mentionnait que les modalités que je
vous ai mentionné précédemment peuvent
être ajustés par le men esprit on est
identifié dix projets sur 22 pour
lesquels il y avait été ajusté et fait
qu'ils avaient été autorisées par le
ministre mais sur recommandation de la
part des équipes d'investissement ok je
comprends donc autrement dit avec toutes
sortes de critères les entreprises ne
respectait pas nécessairement tous les
critères mais investissement québec le
ministère d'économie ont dit ok on fait
bray à ces entreprises là on fait le
prêt mais surtout c'est que si on allait
chez investissement québec au niveau
régional on pouvait se faire refuser
puis si on ne connaît pas à l'apport
d'investissement québec soit les prix
majeurs reçoit les financements
spécialisés mais on
ne l'avait pas secret là et on emmène
identifié une entreprise qui avait cogné
à deux reprises au bureau régional
d'investissement québec mais finalement
on était chez investissement
investissement québec pour soi des
comptes majeurs aux financements
spécialisés et là on lui en octroyer le
prix dans un autre cas c'est une
question de rentabilité
après quelques mois l'entreprise à
elle n'avait pas été rentable il
quelques mois par la suite elle s'est
mise sur la protection de la loi sur la
protection des créanciers ok d'ailleurs
ce sont les entreprises je comprends
mieux avec des critères mais il y avait
un pouvoir discrétionnaire en même temps
du ministre fait que bones du ministre
de l'économie et où et ou
d'investissement québec
il l'était du ministre le le critère
le spécialement c'est mentionné ses
modalités peuvent être ajustés par le
ministre selon les besoins du dossier et
vous vous dites qu'on aurait une
information on aurait dû en savoir plus
sur ce pouvoir discrétionnaire
on aurait dû informer les entreprises
qu'il y avait ce pouvoir discrétionnaire
là parce que les entreprises qui passait
par investissement québec au niveau
régional non mais eux ne le savais pas
qu'il y avait ce critère là et au niveau
régional on a appliqué les critères tels
que je les ai mentionné précédemment
vous avez dit en conférence de presse je
ne sais pas s'il ya eu du favoritisme ou
pas mais il peut en avoir
non pas du tout ea mais l'important
c'est d'être transparent c'est s'assurer
que tout le monde droit aux mêmes règles
du jeu et surtout qu'une bonne reddition
de caen à partir du moment où tout le
monde dans les mêmes règles du jeu et
qui a une bonne reddition temps ci
correct mais c'est quoi le cas
actuellement là on a parlé un peu du
pacte donc du programme d'action
concerté temporaire les entreprises
l'autre programme c'était le pop me le
programme des deux d'urgence pour les
pme qui étaient confiées aux mrc aux
municipalités régionales de comté le
problème ici c'est que les critères
appliqués n'étaient pas les mêmes d'une
mrc à l'autre
effectivement certaines mrc en 3 y est
tout près de 100% des des preuves de
l'inde alors que dans d'autres c'était à
à peine 60 et 5 pour ça lorsqu'on leur a
demandé pourquoi il ya une telle
différence dans le cas des as dans le
cas de celle qu'il octroyait presque
entièrement neuve est un must mesure ben
alors on se doit d'être généreux mais
c'est qu'ils étaient plus sévères disent
eh bien écoutez on est mandataire des
fonds publics donc on se doit d'être
prudent lorsqu'on ouvertes laissant ce
qu'on dit c'est que le ministère de
l'économie aurait dû s'assurer non pas
seulement de compiler les données mais
de s'assurer qu'il y avait une équité
entre les entreprises des différentes et
merci ok madame leclerc c'est très clair
on va faire réagir notre notre ca tantôt
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce soir ça
m'a fait plaisir pour voir nos émissions
en entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici
et redit